As you know I am one of the producers on your movie good boys
Those were vases anyway you guys cannot watch the trailer for your own movie what
You're too young but we've seen their movies like super bad. You saw that movie it is not aged
Well guess you filmed it before black people existed, huh? I'm from Canada. We've also seen sausage party
You saw sausage party. You made a cartoon that's on you dude. Did you like it? Yeah, it was okay. I fell asleep
Well, you know what? I was gonna make some calls and see what I could do, but now fuck y'all
We're in sixth grade now we start doing sixth grade things. I know what cocaine s
About get the fuck out of your pee bag boys only a little shit
Anipals been watching Dateline. She now knows what cocaine is
Hi
yoooooooooooooooo lets get thrassssshed
Tonight is our first middle school party. There's a big girls there. You know, that means drama. No kissing. I'm out
I'm guessing you're not the popular kids in school you
Do not want to go to Sora's party not knowing how to kiss. Hey stranger things go fuck yourself. I
Have an idea I'm kissing. Are you 18 year old?
The guy didn't even know what a kiss he was just licking that woman's asshole wanna kiss an asshole Mack
No, y'all from the future. Oh, we could spy on my neighbor. She told him then for Mia. She starts fires. No, she's a nymphomaniac
Someone who has sex on land and sea
This is how we get the drone back you took my bag. Oh my god, there's Molly in there
In the forest, it's a sex trip. What if a fox eats it and tries to fuck a squirrel. It'll kill them
littler no time to burn everything
You don't get to that party Oh God
I'm fine. I'll just live here
You guys are little badasses pitting us like kids for tweens we know how things work and endorsing
Why are you doing that swing is for sexing people do sex on
Doesn't know a lot of kids he heard some CPR dough we can practice kissing on that snap
You should never kiss someone without their permission. Yeah, I kiss you. What do you like about me? Your sweet smell good
You're really pretty CPR doll I can send